robert de niro just announced that he
will ban President Trump from every one
of his restaurants that's what he said
now folks this is worse than it sounds
for Trump because De Niro owns over 100
McDonald's in the tri-state area
[Applause]
you knew what I was doing okay cool
right speaking of fast food Chili's has
unveiled a sandwich called the boss
burger that contains five kinds of meat
yeah I'm not to be outdone Arby's
released a sandwich that contains some
kind of meat what do we have against
Arby's anyway I'm sure maybe it's a good
place is Arby's any good Andy it's been
a while but
how was that I'm trying to be pulling to
be you know do they buy ad time on the
show not anymore
because we did all these jokes huh why
didn't you step in and stop us that was
some sweet school that was some switch
where we going where is that camera
where is that camera go back to the out
of the shot that's some sweet scratch I
swear to God from now on any time we
blow it in any way with one of our
advertisers I'm gonna lean into the old
sweet scratch camera these are stupid
ideas you shouldn't be applauding them
what else is going on in California a
102 year old man 102 year old man has
set a world record by being the oldest
person to publish a memoir and that cool
I thought so when asked what inspired
the book the man said what book
first Arby's now the elderly right
what's wrong with me
mr. teasing story a New York judge has
ruled that a thirty year old man must
move out of his parents house yeah yeah
30 year old man must move out
it was the landmark case of New York
versus the art history major we got any
art history majors here in the house
now there's one right there how's it
going sir now you're here
there's no swing of the tree on a
Wednesday afternoon the perfect answer
oh my god kids learn a trade
you